ich rufe auf die tagesordnungspunkte
21 a bis 21 so wie die zusatzpunkte
15 17 und 18 beraten mehrere vorlagen zu
einer bedingten regelung zur dritten
beratung des gesetzentwurfs zur rettung
des infektionsschutzgesetzes
liegen ein entschließungsantrag
der fraktionen der afg sowie ein
entschließungsantrag der fraktion die
linke vor über diesen gesetzentwurf
werden wir später namentlich abstimmen
für die aussprache wurde eine dauer von
68 minuten beschlossen bevor ich die
aussprache eröffnet sei mir der hinweis
gestattet sie dürfen auch heute mit der
kollegin katrin göring eckardt und mit
mir hier vorlieb nehmen und wir bleiben
dankeschön
wir bleiben bei den regelungen die wir
seit mittwoch hier praktizieren
natürlich ist das fragerecht und
bemerkung recht gewährleistet aber es
gibt kein natürliches recht auf
kurzinterventionen wenn eine frage
abgewiesen wurde sondern wir fahren dann
in den beratungen fort
ich eröffne die aussprache das wort hat
der bundesminister herr lauterbach
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die panne es leider noch nicht
vorbei und wir brauchen weitere
schutzmaßnahmen und um solche zu
beschließen sind wir heute
zusammengekommen wir haben viel
geschafft aber wir sind nicht an dem
punkt wo schon an freedom day kommen
könnte wir sind heute nicht
zusammengekommen über den frieden zu
sprechen und frieden wäre auch nicht das
ende der schutzmaßnahmen der film die
wäre das ende der pandemie und den
frieden dating besprechen wir somit
nicht heute den frieden die haben wir
gestern gesprochen der in unseren
frieden de können wir erreichen werden
wir diese panne beenden indem wir die
allgemeine impfpflicht beschließen das
ist der einzige sichere weg aus der
familie raus wir können die konnte mir
nicht beschließen in dem wir einfach die
schutzmaßnahmen einstellen wir brauchen
dich schluss maßen solange wir die hohe
zahl und ungeimpften haben tragen muss
immer wieder erinnert werden und wir
wären schon viel weiter als wir sind
wenn uns dies gelingen könnte
wären wir
wenn wir uns heute die fallzahlen
anschauen fast 300.000 fälle werden wir
uns heute die todeszahlen anschauen über
200 menschen sind gestorben das kann uns
nicht zufriedenstellen das ist extrem
unbefriedigend dazu kommt die deutsche
sonderrolle die über 60 jährigen zu
einem hohen maß
um games viel mehr als in unseren
nachbarländern und wir haben darüber
hinaus eine relativ alte bevölkerung
daher brauchen der schutzmaßnahmen
schutzmaßnahmen die in anderen ländern
in diesem umfang nicht mehr notwendig
sind
ich finde es ich muss das haben was
sagen ich finde es traurig wenn wir über
so ein wichtiges thema sprechen und wir
müssen uns an diese zeit diese
niederträchtigen unterstellungen und ein
so verhandlungen das ist einfach
schlicht eine störung ich finde ich mein
ich hoffe doch nicht gut zurecht ich
komme damit gut zurecht aber ich es
spricht wohnen der bedeutung der fragen
die wir hier debattieren die
ernsthaftigkeit wir können dir
unterschiedlicher man sein und wir
werden auch strahlte wir werden in der
sache streiten wir werden das sache
stand aber die ernsthaftigkeit dieser
debatte wird von ihnen in abrede
gestellt das können wir nicht hinnehmen
das ist eine art das ist eine
unglaubliche
verhöhnung der opfer
viele hier hat und ich möchte noch
einmal ich möchte noch etwas sagen wir
sprechen heute über einen schweren
kompromiss das ist aber nicht der
kompromiss das ist nicht der kompromiss
über den wir heute sprechen zwischen
themen freiheit
und dem vorsicht sondern wir sprechen
heute über einen kompromiss
was können wir den menschen noch zumuten
die sich alle an die regeln halten und
unsere kinder was was können wir den
menschen noch zumuten die die regeln
beachten und was sind wir bereit
denjenigen zuzumuten wie gar nichts
bereits hin zu opfern die sich nicht in
das wasser nicht aus die auslands stören
keinen einzigen konstruktiven beitrag im
verlauf in der gesamten fanden bisher
haben lassen können ich sage dass ich
weiß dass ich als epidemiologe gewünscht
hätte wir hätten mehr für diejenigen
touren können sie jetzt im risiko steht
aber wir müssen die rechtliche lage
beachten die rechtliche lage ist die wir
können nicht weiter das gesamte land
unter schutz stellen um eine kleine
gruppe von impfwilligen
und denjenigen die braten nicht bereit
sind die massnahmen mitzutragen
um diese zu schützen die balance ist
geändert das muss ich wenn
herr doktor lauterbach ich habe die zeit
angehalten ich bitte sie hier einen
kleinen moment innezuhalten
und ich sage es heute morgen nur ein
einziges mal
es gilt die allgemeinverfügung und das
heißt die masken können zur rede am pult
beziehungsweise hier oben für die
präsidentinnen abgesetzt werden
für zwischenrufe gilt die masken pflicht
es dürfen in den wenigen minuten die wir
jetzt hier beisammen sind jetzt mehrfach
verstöße auf der rechten seite des
hauses gegen die allgemeinverfügung
und ich werde
entsprechend unseren regelungen dies
hier auch nachdrücklich an ich bitte
darum dass zu beachten sollte
irgendjemand aus welchen gründen auch
immer hier nicht im saal verweilen
können und die maske weitertragen können
dann muss er bitte die debatte
anderweitig verfolgen
sie morgen wieder das wort
minister laut die regelungen die wir
heute vorstellen ist eine regelung die
folgenden der tatsache rechnung stellt
ja durch die omikron variante nicht mehr
die situation dass das gesamte land
gefährdet ist in dem sinne dass wir eine
überlastung dass wir eine überlastung
der kliniken dass wir eine überlassung
der kliniken flächendeckend zu
befürchten haben trotzdem würde es so
sagen dass in vielen stellen tatsächlich
genau diese überlastung kommen wird und
da haben wir die regeln angepasst dass
überall dort wo wir eine überlastung der
krankenhäuser und der
gesundheitsversorgung erwarten müssen
dass dort die hotspot regelung zieht und
wir werden auch weitergehende maßnahmen
ergreifen können und wo das nicht der
fall ist wird es nicht gemacht darauf
haben wir uns angepasst hätten wir dies
nicht gemacht hätten wir kann regel mehr
geld denn dann ist es entweder die
möglichkeit gegeben wir machen die
regeln überall überall maßnahmen auch
dort wo es keine überlastung gibt das
wäre rechtlich nicht gegangen oder
hätten ganz auf die regeln verzichtet
frieden dann hätten wir gar nichts gab
somit ist die begrenzung der regeln auf
die teile deutschlands wo tatsächlich
die überlassung zu befürchten ist das
ist der richtige komponist und das ist
ein kompromiss das ist nicht frei hat
gegen vorsicht sondern das trägt einfach
der tatsache rechnung dass wir so
überhaupt noch zielgerecht reagieren
können und da bitte ich um ihr vertrauen
wir werden das durchsetzen die landtage
werden das auch umsetzen können und wo
ein ganzes land betroffen ist das sind
herr buschmann und ich auch einer man
das wurde immer falsch lag wo ein ganzes
land hotspot ist da kann das ganze land
dann auch als hotspot gelten das ist zum
beispiel etwas was jetzt auch in
mecklenburg-vorpommern
getestet wird somit wir brauchen hier
vertrauen wir brauchen funktionierende
regeln ich bitte sie diesem gesetz
zuzustimmen es wird uns für die nächsten
monate helfen werden die lage nicht
verändert wenn wir andere varianten zu
bekommen werden die
gesundheitsversorgung stärker gefährdet
ist wenn wir beispielsweise eine
gefährliche variante bekommen dann wird
zunächst einmal dieses gesetz aber dann
sind wir auch bereit jederzeit das
infektionsschutzgesetz
erneut anzupassen um dieser neuen lage
rechnung zu tragen
ja das war offensichtlich schon das ende
des der rede des ministers ja viele
waren überrascht dass ausgerechnet karl
lauterbach vom team vorsichtigen das
team freiheit gewechselt ist gemeinsam
mit dem bundesjustizminister der fdp
herr buschmann hat er dieses werk
vorgelegt und jetzt hier bei der
heutigen gegner mal betont wir können
auch die jederzeit wieder zu anderen
maßnahmen zurückkehren der nächste
redner in der debatte ist der
gesundheitspolitische sprecher der cdu
csu tino sorge
kolleginnen und kollegen das gesetz was
wir heute hier abschließend debattieren
hatte zwei klare aufgaben erste aufgabe
lockerung verantwortungsbewusst für das
frühjahr vorbereiten die zweite aufgabe
absicherungen dafür her zu stellen falls
sich die infektions lage
verbessern oder verschlechtern
beides leistet das gesetz nicht viel
mehr erzeugt es einen bürger und dieses
wird das haben nicht nur bier kritisiert
sondern auch alle ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsidenten der bundesländer und
ich finde das schon bemerkenswert der
kollege lauterbach wenn sie sich hier
hinstellen und sagen in der koalition
sei einigkeit darüber erzeugt wurden was
hot spots sind also ich habe jetzt ihren
bundesjustizminister nicht klatschen
sehen bei der sieht das offensichtlich
ganz anders als sie was ein hotspot sein
kann also insofern wenn sie schon nicht
einig sind dann müssen sie sich nicht
wundern wenn die länder nicht wissen wie
sie das umsetzen und ich kann ihnen ganz
klar sagen wir haben ja gestern die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz der länder
gehabt es ist ein absolutes novum in der
geschichte dass 16 ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsidenten dieser
bundesrepublik deutschland in
protokollerklärungen sagen dass das so
nicht geht dass es über erzeugt dass die
ampel auf rot gelb grün steht und im
grunde das chaos mit ansage ist liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und
ich könnte es mir ich könnte es mir sehr
sehr einfach waren ich müsste haben
grunde bloß diese protokolle erklärung
vorlegen deshalb habe ich sie mir doch
mal mitgebracht ich lese mal die ersten
beiden punkte vor dieser
protokollerklärung in top sechs das
sagen
zahlreiche bundesländer
die länder bedauern dass die geplanten
änderungen des infektionsschutzgesetzes
weitestgehend ohne beteiligung der
länder konzipiert worden sind obwohl die
länder maßgeblich für den vollzug
zuständig sind erster punkt weiterer
punkt die nunmehr durch den bund
angestrebte änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes bleibt hinter
diesem schutzniveau zurück zudem ist die
vorgesehene hotspot regelung regelung
rechtlich nicht sicher umsetzbar und
praktisch nicht durchsetzbar liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und da fragt
sich allen ernstes was wollen sie mit
diesem gesetz erreichen glauben sie
ernsthaft dass wir mit diesen gesetzen
rechtssicherheit in den ländern erzeugen
die kolleginnen und kollegen
und das was sie hier gesagt haben herr
kollege laute was ist ja dass sie
definieren wie dieser instrumentenkasten
aussehen könnte und die bundesländer
haben gesagt wir brauchen einen
instrumentenkasten der ihm genau auf
diese dynamische lage reagieren lassen
kann sie haben definiert höhere
pathogenität also wenn ein virus mit
einer höheren pathogenität sich zeigt
dass man dann schneller reagieren kann
muss was sie nicht definieren ist was
ist höhere pathogenität sie sagen in
bereichen wo besonders hohe neue
infektionen kommen kann reagiert werden
keiner weiß was meinen sie mit besonders
hohem neuinfektionen und die drohende
klinik überlastung im hinblick auf die
hotspots dass es genau der punkt der
maßgebliche punkt den sie innerhalb der
koalition nicht geklärt haben der
kollege lauterbach und da ist sollten
sie dringend nacharbeiten liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und deshalb
kann ich ihnen nur sagen wir werden
dieses gesetz ablehnen nicht nur weil es
handwerklich schlecht ist weil es in den
einzelheiten nicht geklärt es bei sein
einziger unscharfer rechtsbegriff ist
wir werden es als opposition ablehnen
aber auch ihre kolleginnen und kollegen
in den ländern frau die wie
beispielsweise hat gestern der schon
angekündigt noch vor verabschiedung des
gesetzes dass es nachgebessert werden
muss also insofern gehe ich davon aus
dass uns derzeit trage wiedersehen
werden vielen dank
tino semmer dass die cdu/csu wirkliches
gesetzt als handwerklich schlecht
gemacht das gesetz ablegen ablehnen
besonders kritisierte sorge die hotspot
riegel und zucken klare definitionen das
gleiche taten ja die
ministerpräsidenten gestern
jetzt die stufe der vorsitzende des
gesundheitsausschusses von den blüten
[Applaus]
heute reden sollen doch auch ihn hat als
corona virus erwischt dass er dafür
spott und häme
hier sofort und auch im netz ab bekommt
das liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist
unerträglich
sie haben gerade zurück letzter sagt was
sie hier machen lieber janus unsere
volle solidarität
es ist unerträglich am menschen sind
krank und er ist einer von etwa 300.000
menschen die sich derzeit täglich neu
infizieren und wir wünschen allen von
ihnen einen milden verlauf
doch leider doch leider liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wissen wir dass
es jeden tag auch menschen schwer trifft
das über 200 menschen täglich sterben
und longo witt jeden und jede treffen
kann auch kinder wir dürfen longo wird
nicht unterschätzen
und bei der frage auf unser
gesundheitssystem überlastet ist sollten
wir nicht nur auf die intensivstation
gucken die peripheren station der
krankenhäuser sind zurzeit stark unter
druck alle kolleginnen und kollegen dort
herzlich aus der pflege alle arbeiten am
limit und überall sind die menschen in
unserem land unter druck auch psychisch
und der ton verschärft sich nicht nur
hier auch sonst aber wir können diese
pandemie nur gemeinsam überwinden liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
[Musik]
uns auch innerhalb
koalition ist es in unserer demokratie
notwendig kompromisse zu finden
das ist das wesen der demokratie
aus meiner sicht als ärztin als
gesundheitspolitikerin aus meiner
fraktion und im übrigen auch der
mehrheit der bevölkerung braucht es für
einen guten infektionsschutz vermutlich
mehr als das was heute in diesem gesetz
vorliegt
wir wissen dass er fit wie zwei masken
einen guten schutz vor ansteckung bieten
und es wäre gut weiterhin präventiv zu
addieren und die masken pflicht
flächendeckend beizubehalten
und es ist kein geheimnis dass wir auch
innerhalb der koalition unterschiedliche
positionen dazu hatten welche maßnahmen
jetzt bundesweit weiterhin nötig sind
aber
kein gesetz wäre sehr viel schlechter
gewesen als dieses gesetz was ja
weiterhin
schutzmaßnahmen beinhaltet
und darum werden wir als bündnis 90 die
grünen auch zustimmen auch wenn wir uns
deutlich mehr gewünscht hätten weil das
ist das was innerhalb der ampel
vereinbar war und worst case wäre
gewesen alle schutzmaßnahmen auslaufen
zu lassen
hier also mit diesem gesetz schützen wir
natürlich mehr als ohne gesetz hier ist
der spatz in der hand natürlich deutlich
mehr schutz als die taube auf dem dach
ich hoffe sehr
dass die maske trägt aber auch die
masken für weiter benutzt wird und zwar
nicht nur für sich selbst sondern auch
für andere besonders verletzliche
personen wer diese schützen möchte trägt
in diesem frühjahr weiter masken
beispielsweise im supermarkt denn dort
kaufen menschen ein mit kleinen kindern
menschen die sich nicht impfen lassen
konnten bisher und auch diese sind auf
unsere solidarität angewiesen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es ist so
auf die länder kommt jetzt eine große
verantwortung zu sie können die
übergangsfrist bis zum zweiten april
verlängern sie können schutzmaßnahmen
fortführen und von der hotspot regelung
gebrauch machen viele länder wie bremen
berlin baden württemberg gehen schon in
diese richtung dass es vermutlich sehr
klug und klar bleibt wenn die neuen
maßnahmen nicht ausreichen werden müssen
wir nach noja denn die pandemie ist noch
nicht vorbei und wir werden sie
hat es so gesagt man hat sich gebeugt
den willen der fdp den handlich lieben
auch klare aussagen von elano stammen
ist er krank und tubisten von hier genau
wie zum beispiel die bundestags
präsidentin bärbel bas der bundestags-
vizepräsident wolfgang kubicki aydan
özoguz alle an corona erkrankt und mit
ihnen zusammen fast 300.000 bundesbürger
am heutigen tage rekord präsidenten und
der bundestag und der bundesrat lockern
die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen die nächste
rednerin kommt von der 8 christina
endlich wieder normal wieder frei leben
wollen ist nichts weiter als eine
beruhigungspille
denn die wenigen erleichterungen können
jederzeit aufgehoben werden ganz nach
lust und laune
da es keine eindeutigen parameter für
die hotspots gibt die korona maßnahmen
und hören schon deshalb komplett vom
tisch weil das dafür erhobene kriterium
zu keinem zeitpunkt erfüllt war zu
keinem zeitpunkt gab es eine überlastung
der krankenhäuser oder der
intensivstationen
evidenzbasierte studien zur wirksamkeit
der korona maßnahmen gibt es nicht deren
schädlichkeit ist jedoch hinlänglich
bewiesen
insbesondere bei kindern und
jugendlichen haben sie zu massiven
körperlichen und psychischen schäden
geführt ängstlichkeit depressionen es
und sprachstörungen bis hin zu generell
entwicklungsstörungen all das ist jedoch
nur die spitze des eisberges das tragen
von masken führt zu einem anstieg von
blutdruck und herzfrequenz kopfschmerzen
schwindel konzentrationsschwäche und
hautirritationen die in einer metastudie
zum masken induzierten
erschöpfungssymptomen beschrieben wurde
ich zitiere aus einer stellungnahme bei
einer öffentlichen sitzung der
kinderschutz kommission des deutschen
bundestages am 19 september 2020 von
professor doktor michael klundt zitat
alle entscheidungen und maßnahmen der
politik seit märz april 2020 wurden
völkerrechts verstoßen und bundesgesetz
niedrig ohne vorrangige berücksichtigung
des kindeswohls vorgenommen der
kindeswohl vorrang ist nicht nur
ignoriert worden sondern aus dem
kinderschutz wurde plötzlich der schutz
vor kindern sie wurden als wir und
verbreiter wie objekte behandelt diese
instrumentelle behandlung von kindern
betrachte ich als eine form von
kindeswohlgefährdung zitat ende
wie recht prozesse und damit hatte
beweist ein bewohner szenarien papier
des bundesministeriums vorwärts 2020
darin können sie auf seite 13 lesen um
die gewünschte schockwirkung zu erzielen
müssen die konkreten auswirkungen einer
durchseuchung auf die menschliche
gesellschaft verdeutlicht werden und
unter punkt 2 steht dass man kindern die
schuld dafür geben sollen dass ihre
eltern anstecken die dann qualvoll zu
hause sterben das sei der schrecklichste
was ein kind je erleben könnte diese
dieses unmenschliche leid das den
kindern damit zugefügt wurde wird für
immer mit ihrem namen verbunden sein
doch nicht nur die kinder sind
geschädigt sondern die ganze
gesellschaft als soziale w sind wir auf
kontakte umarmungen und nähe angewiesen
sie haben diese menschliche nur
bedürfnisse verboten und mit welchem
ergebnis
die inzidenz sind so hoch wie nie allein
das zeugt von der völligen unwirksamkeit
aller maßnahmen das einzige was sie
damit erreicht haben ist die schwächung
der eigenen immunabwehr wir brauchen für
ein funktionierendes immunsystem den
kontakt mit viren wir brauchen die
bewegung an der frischen luft wir
brauchen sauerstoff zum atmen und wird
auch in liebevolle umarmungen wären sie
unserem volk endlich ein
menschenwürdiges leben und
lebensfreude zurück das ist die beste
medizin
vielen dank
ist der baum war das von der htg auf die
winter einen tag ein indem sie fordert
alle kohler maßnahmen für kinder sofort
beendet und wenn man mal hinten liest
was der
bundestag beschließen soll dann kommt er
eine sehr witzige passagen unter punkt 3
fordert die fdp des bundestages
einzurechnen in der die bundesregierung
die kinder um verzeihung bittet lukas
gähwiler jetzt stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender der fdp
sehr geehrte frau präsident sind meine
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen lieber
herr sorge es hat mich überrascht
dass sie so sehr auf die klare und
eindeutige einhaltung des blinden folgen
quasi der mpk wochen würden ich kann
mich daran erinnern dass auch dieses mal
einstimmig alle ministerpräsident für
eine allgemeine impfpflicht gestimmt
haben und ich wäre würde mich wundern ob
die cdu nach den vorträgen von gestern
die csu dem auch so folgen würde das
wäre doch eine ganz andere debatte
anlage hervor dass ich wäre vorsichtig
mit dem forderungen wie man aussieht ich
glaube aber und ich will ihnen das gar
nicht weil das zeigt ja eine sache wir
sind lernfähig wir entwickeln uns weiter
während wir unser wissen weiter und ich
glaube dass es auch das was man in
dieser pandemie sieht dass wir in der
diskussion die wir hier führen sehen und
das ist auch das was wir in den
richtigen und notwendigen maßnahmen
sehen die wir zum schutz
sehen müssen denn meine damen und herren
die nicht die freiheit von
einschränkungen des begründung bedürftig
die einschränkung der freiheit ist
begründung bedürftig und das müssen wir
bei jeder bei jeder einzelnen maßnahme
die wir treffen immer wieder vor augen
haben wir müssen wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass wir politik so ausgestalten dass
nur das an den wenigen freiheits
einschränkungen möglich ist das
notwendig ist und das ist das was wir
mit diesem gesetzesentwurf das ist das
was wir mit diesem vorschlag den
geschützen auf der einen seite sorgen
aber dafür dass wir so weit wie es
irgendwie geht zurück zur normalität
kommen
die herausforderung vor der wir stehen
ist natürlich dass sich pandemie
geschehen das sich aber auch wissen
entwickelt und so war es ja ganz klar
dass vor dem schleier der unwissenheit
am anfang der pandemie entscheidung
getroffen wurden bei denen wir heute
sagen sie waren damals falsch oder
unnötig aber zu dem zeitpunkt wo sie
getroffen wurden hätten wir sie nicht
anders treffen können deswegen haben wir
als freie demokraten wie auch damals
schon unterstützt in einer ganz anderen
position und auch konstellation wir
haben aber gesehen dass sich diese
pandemie verändert wir haben gesehen
dass wir die mensa infektionszahlen
haben dass wir eine sehr hohe inzidenz
haben aber dass die inzidenz heute nicht
mehr der ausschlaggebende faktor
einzig und allein die überlastung der
krankenhäuser ist es was wir politisch
betrachten müssen was jetzt in zukunft
die dann tage beachten müssen und nicht
die frage inwiefern es funktionieren
kann dass wir immer weitere instanzen
immer unterschiedlicheren konstellation
deswegen meine damen und herren
müssen wir auch weiterhin
freiheit und verantwortung kommen aber
es gibt ja auch diejenigen die sagen
quasi wie monsters kühl wenn es nicht
nötig ist ein gesetz zu machen ist es
nötig kein gesetz zu machen das wäre
aber an dieser stelle auch der falsche
weg gewesen gar keine maßnahmen gar
keine schutzkonzepte keine möglichkeit
für die länder ist hinzugekommen bei
einem hotspot regelungen zu treffen das
wäre auch der falsche weg die kollegen
sind das wäre kollege gestatten sie eine
frage oder bemerkung des kollegen willi
mir manches kühne zu ende bringen und
das ging leider nicht nein danke
diese idee
dieses gesetz
so zu auszugestalten dass wir auf der
einen seite schutz bei hotspots haben
und auf der anderen seite
dafür sorgen dass die menschen in den
alltag zurückfinden dass die menschen
ihre verantwortung umsetzen und ihrer
verantwortung gerecht werden können das
ist es was wir politisch einfordern
müssen denn meine damen und herren die
menschen in deutschland sind ja keine
kleinen kinder wir verbieten niemanden
masken zu tragen wir ermöglichen den
menschen ihre eigene verantwortung
selbst die hand geben und das tue gern
auch einer liberalen idee und das ist es
doch meine damen und herren was wir in
den nächsten wochen und monaten im
nächsten halben jahr sehen werden das
heißt aber nicht dass wir nicht vor neun
varianten vor neuen entwicklungen in der
pandemie geschützt werden das heißt auch
nicht dass wir nicht lernfähig werden
denn natürlich können wir weiterhin
lernen natürlich werden wir auch zum
herbst wenn es notwendig ist mehr
beschiss können wir können auch über den
sommer mehr schießen denn politik ist
handlungsfähig politik beschließt nicht
etwas das in stein gemeißelt ist sondern
politik reagiert und kluge pandemie
politik reagiert klug und das ist es was
wir mit diesem gesetzentwurf machen
meine damen und herren
sie sehen auf jeden fall nicht anders
der zeitpunkt jetzt ist völlig richtig
in diese richtung weiter zu gehen wir
sehen im europäischen vergleich dass wir
mit diesem gesetz zumindest nicht mehr
alleine dasteht wir sehen dass wir mit
diesen änderungen einen gemeinsamen weg
aus der pandemie gehen können
und natürlich ist es wichtig dass die
menschen weiterhin
verantwortungsbewusst mit der pandemie
natürlich ist es wichtig dass die
menschen sich impfen lassen natürlich
wissen wir dass auch weitere
entwicklungen in der pandemie nach dem
19 nicht zu ende sind und wir wissen
trotzdem dass es viele menschen in und
die allermeisten menschen in deutschland
gibt die verantwortungsbewusst mit ihrer
freiheit umgehen und das ist es was wir
mit diesem gesetz schaffen deswegen
vielen dank für die debatte vielen dank
für dieses gesetz und auf ein gutes
weiteres
wie optimistisch der treiber dieses
gesetzes quasi alle maßnahmen können
seien ab sonntag wegfallen nur im
begrenzten bereich gilt dann noch die
masten vielleicht heute gab es 226 tote
und die menschen die am wochenende
erkranken werden oder montag kommender
woche die ihm werden dann teilweise in
14 tagen drei wochen oder später in
dieser statistik erscheinen und so
grausam es ist aber so harmlos wie das
hier immer dargestellt wird ist die
omikron ikon variante bei weitem auch
nicht susanne fritzsche jetzt für die
präsidentinnen sie erfährt die
kolleginnen und kollegen herr minister
die bundesregierung möchte gerne die
fortschritts koalition seien aber was
bitte ist daran fortschrittlich dauernd
gesetze im schweinsgalopp durch das
parlament zu treiben die dann auch noch
handwerklich und inhaltlich schlecht
sind
dieses verfahren wenn infektion das
haben wir jetzt seit zwei jahren und die
ampel die top tatsächlich auch noch die
groko nur den pflege bonus den haben sie
nicht innerhalb einer woche hinbekommen
an dem doktor ziert seit monaten herum
dass es peinlich meine damen und herren
omikron verursacht zum glück weniger
schwere verläufe und ja die
ausgangssituation ist eine andere als
vor zwei jahren aber bei einem
höchststand an infektionen und bei
täglichen longo bit und todesfällen
lockert man doch nicht von 100 auf
nahezu null
zu gunsten der freedom day partei
genannt fdp geben bundesregierung und
gesundheitsminister der ansonsten der
ewige mahner in der pandemie gewesen ist
hier eine politische bankrotterklärung
ab
ihre regionale hotspot regelungen
geschafft einen flickenteppich an
unterschiedlichen maßnahmen sie lassen
damit die bundesländer im regen stehen
und sie fördern auch noch den föderalen
über bildungs und
unterbietungswettbewerb das ist wirklich
absurd meine damen und herren
und apropos absurd sie schaffen die
masken pflicht als basisschutz ab obwohl
masken nachweislich vor infektionen
schützen diskutieren aber gleichzeitig
über die einführung einer allgemeinen
impfpflicht diese impfpflicht ist aber
wesentlich freiheitseinschränkende als
sich die pflicht sich für eine halbe
stunde in bus oder bahn oder im
supermarkt die maske und mund und nase
zu binden
und dann entschuldigung dieses blöde
argument von der fdp der mann dürfte ja
weiterhin die maske tragen es geht aber
nicht nur um eigenen schutz sondern es
geht um fremdschutz und das offenbar zu
deutlich ihr krudes verständnis von
freiheit nämlich freiheit von
solidarität und rücksicht
die wohlgeraten truppen die sie
angeblich schützen wollen die leben
nämlich nicht nur im heim sie leben
mitten in unserer gesellschaft
pflegende angehörige eltern von kindern
mit vorgang vorerkrankungen die kommen
offensichtlich in ihren
paralleluniversum gar nicht vor es ist
beschämend und
um es auf allen ebenen absurd zu machen
wird der infektionsschutz am
arbeitsplatz auch noch runter gefahren
wenn tests machten und homeoffice der
beliebigkeit der arbeitgeber unterliegen
ist die gesundheit der beschäftigten
gefährdet und es ist völlig inakzeptabel
nach zwei jahren kann jenny ist doch
wirklich nicht zu viel verlangt einen
plan vorzulegen der uns durch diese und
künftige pandemien bringt die linke
erzielt zu einen antrag eingebracht und
wir brauchen klare wenn dann regelungen
die bei vergleichbaren
infektionsgeschehen auch vergleichbare
maßnahmen gewährleisten kostenfreie test
auch pcr tests und eine ausweitung der
impfkampagne da ist nach wie vor luft
nach oben und
und einen rechtsanspruch auf
infektionsschutz am arbeitsplatz und auf
home office
meine damen und herren die große
mehrheit in diesem land hätte ich jetzt
seit zwei jahren besonnen und
solidarisch an die regeln aber durch
intransparenz hauruckverfahren falsche
versprechungen zb auf ein ende der
pandemie geht mit jeder neuen welle mehr
vertrauen in politik und staat verloren
ihr gesetz trägt weiter dazu bei und
deswegen reden wir es unter um ab vielen
dank
susanne fischer stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender der linken hat
kritisiert für den beleg pflege bonus
brauche die ampel monate und so ein
gesetz hier wird direkt vom zaun
gebrochen die fdp verfolge einen
merkwürdigen freiheitsbegriff wenn sie
immer wieder argumentiert man könne ja
weiter die maske tragen dass die auch in
den brandschutz und vereinigungen diesen
freiheit so versteht es die fdp sei
angeblich seine freiheit von solidarität
und rücksicht so wie sie es hätte die
spd kolleginnen und kollegen die zahlen
der letzten tage die uns immer wieder
erreichen machen glaube ich eins
deutlich dass wir weiter sehr
verantwortungsvoll mit dieser aktuellen
situation und den pandemie geschehen
umgehen müssen und das vollkommen
richtig auch aufgrund der aktuellen lage
was karl lauterbach gerade auch aus
geführt hat wir werden mit diesem gesetz
sicherlich keinen frieden in diesem land
haben und das ist auch nicht etwas was
die ampel letztendlich mit diesem gesetz
verfolgt sondern es ein weiterer
verantwortungsvoller umgang mit der
aktuellen situation denn ich will es
noch mal deutlich machen die regelung in
28 a und 28 b des gelten
infektionsschutzgesetzes die würde wenn
wir keine fortgesetzte regelung finden
würde die wir heute auf den weg bringen
auslaufen und das würde bedeuten wenn
wir nichts tun würde es künftig gar
keine maßnahmen wie test oder masten
pflicht mehr geben können und das vor
dem hintergrund der aktuellen zahl
kurzum die rechtsgrundlagen für die
länder würden wenn wir heute nicht
dieses gesetz auf den weg bringen
ersatzlos wegfallen und das kann aus
unserer sicht nicht sein und darum ist
es richtig diesen vertretbaren
kompromiss heute auch auf den weg zu
bringen
das will ich sagen es ist wichtig diesen
praktikablen kompromiss den wir als
ampel koalition verhandelt haben auf den
weg zu bringen die situation ist anders
als infektionsschutzgesetz änderungen
die wir in den vergangenen jahren gehabt
haben da wir eine hohe zahl an impfungen
letztendlich auch haben die nachweislich
vor einem schweren verlauf auch schützen
oder unwillig dank sagen an
bundesgesundheitsminister laut aber ort
als auch im bundesjustizminister
buschmann die gemeinsam mit uns satz
koalitionen diesen kompromiss auf den
weg gebracht haben und herr sorge sie
wussten dass vielleicht nicht beide
haben dem zugestimmt nur man darf auf
der regierungsbank nicht klatschen darum
waren sie vielleicht in den letzten
jahren dirigiert das in spanien mehr
ausgegeben hat aber das ist eigentlich
konferenz im bundestag aber vielleicht
wirst du dir das an der stelle noch
nicht ich glaube der kompromisses
vertretbar ergibt eine perspektive auch
im rahmen einer verantwortungsvollen
öffnungs perspektive schritte die auch
vereinbart worden sind aber wir müssen
uns glaube ich sehr deutlich bewusst
machen gerade für die situation des
kommenden herbst und winter das müssen
wir vorsorgen wir wollen dass diese
pandemie beherrscht wird und vor dem
hintergrund ist es wichtig vorsorge zu
treffen letztendlich mit einer
allgemeinen impfpflicht die wir anfang
april in zweiter dritter lesung auf den
weg bringen wollen das ist ein
eingewiesen gestatten sie eine frage
oder bemerkung des kollegen so ja
selbstverständlich
vielen dank herr kollege wie sieht das
in die zwischenfrage zulassen dass sie
mich ja direkt angesprochen haben soll
will ich sie ganz kurz fragen finden sie
das parlamentarische verfahren normal
und als ein zeichen guter zusammenarbeit
wenn noch vor der verabschiedung des
gesetzes 16 ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten der länder sagen das
gesetz ist schlecht das geht so nicht
sie wissen nicht wie sie es umsetzen
soll und finden sie es normal dass noch
vor der ersten lesung dieses gesetzes
die anhörung stattfinden muss weil es
zeitlich nicht anders ging obwohl man
seit monaten wusste dass hier neue
regelung auf den weg gebracht werden
müssen
sehr geehrter kollege sorge haben sie
einmal vielen dank für die zwischenphase
entschuldigung
nicht so
und den letzten halbsatz der ist es
durch das mikro ein bisschen
untergegangen und das verbände sagen
dass das völlig atypisch sei das heißt
sie bekommen den gesetzentwurf um 0 18
an dem sonntag zugesandt und soll bis 10
uhr am montagmorgen dazu stellung in
finden sie das alles normal im
parlamentarischen verfahren vielen dank
sehr geehrter kollege sorge haben sie
vielen dank für die zwischenfrage weil
mir dass die möglichkeit gibt und ich
sehe den früheren gesundheitsminister
jens sparen ja auch hier heute bei der
debatte sitzen ich habe seit mai 2020
einige änderungen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes mitverhandeln
wurden auch in der großen koalition und
ich kann ihnen sagen dass dieses
verfahren sicherlich zeitlich sehr
anspruchsvoll gewesen ist dass es sich
aber wohltuend abhebt von dem was wir
unter der leitung von helge braun im
kanzleramt den teilen erlebt haben wir
haben teilweise sehr hektische
verhandlungen geführt werden teilweise
sind aus dem kanzleramt damals sachen an
die bild -zeitung gesprochen worden
daran kann ich nur sagen es gibt sich
sehr wohltuend ab wie die
bundesregierung diese änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes in der
ampelkoalition an ansonsten würde ich
mich freuen wenn sie stehen bleiben
solange ich ihre frage auch beantwortet
ob das gebiete auch der respekt
untereinander bei kolleginnen und
kollegen
es ist letztendlich ein kompromiss den
wir auch den weg bringen der die
menschen die wohl rebellengruppen ganz
besonders schützen möchte und in den
blick nimmt er ist aber auch ein
kompromiss der auch die
verhältnismäßigkeit watt und darum ist
es richtig wohl der alle gruppen
besonders zu schützen es ist auch
richtig die massen pflicht gerade im
öpnv letztendlich auch weiter zu
behalten das ist auch richtig dass wir
den ländern die möglichkeit geben bei
vorliegen einer konkreten gefahr einer
sich dynamisch ausbreitenden
infektionsrate gehende schutzmaßnahmen
im rahmen einer hotspot regelung auf den
weg zu bringen und das heißt die länder
können letztendlich für kreise für
kreisfreie städte aber auch für das
gesamte bundesland diese hotspot
regelungen auf den weg bringen das halte
ich für richtig und ich sage es auch
sehr deutlich ich finde es richtig dass
die länder den weg über die landtage
gehen müssen die kolleginnen und
kollegen in den landtagen können dass
verantwortlich machen die werden das gut
machen das ist die demokratische
rückkopplung die wir an der stelle auch
drauf
jetzt habe ich allerdings auch den einen
oder anderen hinweis ja gerade auch von
norman mehr sorge auch von ihrer rede
bezüglich der ministerpräsidenten ich
will auch mal einen blick in die
christdemokratische praxis in den
bundesländern letztendlich werfen wo
waren denn die verschärfungen aufgrund
einer steigenden infektionsgeschehen in
nordrhein westfalen von
ministerpräsident wies nach dem kölner
karneval wo hat die landesregierung denn
da die entsprechenden ähnlichkeiten
gesehen voranzugehen und wenn ich mir
anschaue was derzeit in der korona
schutz verordnung des landes
nordrhein-westfalen geregelt ist und was
das land mit den öffnungszeiten
voranbringen bilder nordrhein westfalen
dann ist das übrigens deckungsgleich mit
dem was wir in dem zukünftigen
infektionsschutzgesetz den ländern zur
verfügung stellt von daher scheint ihre
ministerpräsidenten an dem punkt doch
sehr zufrieden zu sein und von daher
verstehe ich den einen oder anderen
punkte an der stelle nicht will aber
auch mal deutlich machen
und da will ich mal einen blick nach
bayern werfen und entschuldigen sie herr
dobrindt das was ich jetzt aufhöre ist
die gemütslage des bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten von gestern abend es
kann durchaus sein dass er seine meinung
bis heute morgen geändert hat
das ist ein entscheidender
bayern kraft ab kommenden montag die
masken pflicht für grundschüler in den
schulen ab die übergangsregelung die wir
den bundesländern gewähren würde die
möglichkeit geben dies noch bis zum
zweiten viertel auch zu machen dann kann
es letztendlich ja nicht so sein dass
wie markus söder das schildert hier
maßnahmen die er zur verfügung hätte für
ihn nicht ausreichend sind das heißt er
macht gar nicht gebrauch von
übergangsregelungen wie wir ihn im
infektionsschutzgesetz zur verfügung
stellt und das muss ich schon sagen das
was düsseldorf münchen da letztendlich
vor ort machen das ist in einer gewissen
weise unglaubwürdig und widerspricht dem
was sie heute an dem gesetz kritischen
und vielen dank ihr aufnehmen
wird diese frist
die der bundestag diskutiert in zweiter
lesung die änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
die nächste rednerin kommt von der cdu
den día de
und stellvertretende parteivorsitzende
der christen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen heute beraten
wir auch den antrag der cdu csu fraktion
zur verlängerung der korona bedingten
elterngeld regelungen und ich muss schon
sagen wir haben uns doch sehr gewundert
als im rahmen ihres entwurfs zum so
deckt bei all den verlängerungen der
korona bedingten sonderregeln niemand
aus ihrer koalition und auch nicht die
zuständige bundesfamilienministerin
spiegel an die verlängerung der korona
bedingten elterngeld regeln gedacht hat
aber wir hätten ja gern als opposition
und deswegen freue ich mich dass sie
unseren änderungsantrag vollständig
übernommen haben aber eins werden
schon in der schule beim schreiben das
selbstständige denken nicht einstellen
denn auch die besseren schüler machen
meinen fehler wie sie haben nämlich auch
den redaktionellen fehler der uns
unterlaufen ist in unserem
änderungsantrag in der begründung eins
zu eins übernommen
vielleicht besteht ja noch die
möglichkeit der korrektur schauen sie
mal nach wir haben verwiesen auf sanft 3
in paragraf 2 absatz 1 bgb es müsste
satz 4 sein und der fehler ist ihnen
unterlaufen vielleicht korrigieren sie
das aber
es geht uns um die es geht uns um die
vielen eltern die in den nächsten tagen
ein kind erwarten die in den vergangenen
tagen und wochen eltern geworden sind es
geht um die eltern die die in den
vergangenen drei monaten pandemie
bedingt in kurzarbeit waren oder
arbeitslosengeld bezogen haben deren
kinder krank waren oder die die kinder
zu hause betreuen mussten weil die
einrichtungen kitas schule pandemie
pandemie bedingt geschlossen waren diese
eltern müssen zukünftig nicht mehr
fürchten weniger elterngeld zu bekommen
denn die monate in denen sie
kurzarbeitergeld arbeitslosengeld
kindergeld oder andere pandemie bedingte
sonderregelung erhalten haben die können
außer ausgeklammert werden es geht aber
auch um die eltern die aufgrund der
pandemie den partnerschafts bonus nicht
bekommen können weil einfach die zeiten
so waren wie sie sind auch diese eltern
müssen nun nicht mehr fürchten dass sie
keine elterngeld bekommen oder noch viel
schlimmer es zurückzahlen müssen für all
diese jungen eltern haben wir uns als
opposition stark gemacht und letztlich
auch die koalition überzeugt die
pandemie bedingten sonderregeln werden
im bundes eltern und dem
elternzeitgesetz nicht nur verlängert
sondern rückwirkend ab ende dezember
22 gelten und das ist eine gute
nachricht vielen dank
[Applaus]
wenn man einen fehler macht und da wird
abgeschrieben das ist natürlich dann
so der nächste
bündnis gegebenen und des euro ist
mitglied im ausschuss für arbeit und
soziales
[Applaus]
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren ich
will mit großer ehrlichkeit diese rede
beginnen die debatte heute die
abstimmungen die anstehen nachher die
fallen mir persönlich äußerst schwer
weil ich bezweifle dass das vorliegende
infektionsschutzgesetz letztlich der
lage die wir haben angemessen ist wir
hätten uns auch andere auch
weitergehende regelungen vorstellen
können und dass es auch kein geheimnis
in diesem haus über steigenden
infektionszahlen immer mehr
krankenhauseinweisungen auch vielen
toten jeden tag die basis
schutzmaßnahmen so weit nach unten zu
fahren so rigoros nach unten zu fahren
dass es nicht die vorsorgen die politik
die wir gerne auch hier beschlossen
hätten zumindest die masken pflicht
zumindest die masken pflicht in
innenräumen hätte bestehen bleiben
müssen und lieber kollege köhler liebe
fdp wenn menschen mit vorerkrankungen
sich zu hause einschließen müssen weil
unsere gesellschaft weil wir zu
rücksichtslos dafür sind masken in
öffentlichen räumen zu tragen dann ist
das nicht mein verständnis von freiheit
heute hier zu stück zuzustimmen fällt
mir schwer und dennoch werbe ich dafür
weil die alternative keine regelungen zu
haben keine alternative ist und weil wir
viele andere regelungen heute hier haben
die wir mit beschließen es geht um die
eltern das wurde gerade gesagt das ist
richtig es geht aber auch um die vielen
sozialen einrichtungen die wir in
deutschland haben und die wir
selbstverständlich sichern müssen und
vor dem bankrott zu schützen müssen das
sozialdienstleister einsatz gesetz ist
ein schutzschirm den ganz viele brauchen
und ganz viele sind so froh darüber dass
wir es schaffen dass heute hier zu
verabschieden und schon allein deswegen
ist es wichtig dass wir weiter
gesetzliche regelungen haben
wir brauchen und wir brauchen so dringt
dringend die wohlfahrtsverbände die
müttergenesungswerkes wir brauchen die
freien kita träger wir brauchen die
anbieter von sprachkursen
selbstverständlich wir brauchen
einrichtungen für menschen mit
behinderungen all das ist das was wir in
der gesellschaft gerade in einer solchen
pandemie brauchen und die menschen die
dort arbeiten die haben über ihre
belastungsgrenze in den letzten monaten
gearbeitet die haben unterstützt die
haben die haben geholfen die haben
unterrichtet so wie es eben gerade noch
gegen und diese menschen die verdienen
respekt die verdienen anerkennung die
verdienen aber vielmehr die verdienen
dass wir hier heute sicherstellen dass
sie gut finanziert und sicher
aufgestellt auch in dieser
krisensituation ihre arbeit machen
können
[Applaus]
und wo
und wo könnte das plastischer werden als
wenn wir uns die kinder und jugend reha
anschauen in dieser pandemie und das
wissen wir alle haben kinder und
jugendliche so unglaublich auch immer
wieder ertragen müssen sie haben immer
wieder gelitten und wenn wir diesen
kindern und jugendlichen eine zukunft
geben wollen dann müssen wir die soziale
infrastruktur sichern die diesen kindern
und jugendlichen hilft die dort hingehen
wo die probleme sind und die menschen
dann auch eine perspektive aus dieser
schwierigen lage heraus entwickeln kann
bei all diesen
bei all diesen institutionen bei all
diesen institutionen herrscht weiter
ausnahmezustand und dann kann man so oft
wie man will hier in diesem parlament
auch den normalzustand herbeireden es
wird dadurch nicht besser dort herrscht
ausnahmezustand und so viele haben mit
mir jetzt in den wochen davor gesprochen
und darum gebeten dass wir diese gesetze
verlängern genau das tun wir ich habe
große sorgen dass das bedeutet dass das
was wir heute beschließen nicht
ausreicht und dennoch ist es wichtig
genau das zu tun was wir heute tun
dankeschön
wo abgeordnete beiden wir können hier
exakt 1 redezeit protokoll und managen
auch mit den fraktionen bei redezeit
überziehung das redezeiten entsprechend
abgezogen werden so wie wir das auch
seit mittwochmittag und im übrigen nicht
nur in dieser woche praktizieren das
präsidium brauchte dazu jetzt eine
unterstützung aus dem leben
hat der abgeordnete stefan brandner will
die fdp
offensichtlich war dafür der ht
angemeldet worden dass der florida keys
zu lange gesprochen hat und frauke
darauf hingewiesen dass wird wie gehabt
gehandhabt der nächste redner aus der
fraktion erhält einfach weniger redet
seiner modernen das
infektionsschutzgesetz steht damit auf
der tagesordnung ein schwieriges thema
wenn man den zensoren von youtube und co
entgehen möchte ich versuch's trotzdem
es ist erst ein paar stunden her dass
herr lauterbach einer der größten
islamistischen in diesem lande hier von
ihr vor eine ein wahres horrorszenario
an die wand gemalt hat zwar im rahmen
der impfzwang debatte am gestrigen tag
hat die debatte scharf erfolg der
lauterbach sie haben eine knappe minute
gebraucht und in dieser knappen minute
in am anfang ihrer rede war ein halbes
dutzend an tische schreckensszenarien
die alle über uns hereinbrechen werden
ich sage ihnen voraus kein einziges
dieser schreckensszenarien wird ein
treffen der lauter macht sie sind ein
lügner von hier vorne gewesen immer
schon und sie werden es auch bleiben und
ich denke daran ihre aussage im herbst
20 21 mit krokodilstränen haben sie
prognostiziert bis märz 2022 seien in
deutschland alle geimpft genesen oder
leider gestorben das lebende beispiel
lauterbach steht hier vor ihnen weder
geimpft noch gelesen und auch noch nicht
gestorben das mag jetzt daran liegen
dass noch nicht ende märz ist sie haben
sich heute was den märz an geht nicht
festgelegt das mag vielleicht daran
liegen dass die großen unsinn erzählt
haben ich vermute mal letzteres und
erwarte von ihnen der lauter wacht dass
sie sich von vielen millionen menschen
die sie mit dieser aussage in angst und
panik versetzt haben zumindest
entschuldigen es sind nicht millionen
menschen gestorben die nicht geimpft
dann macht es die sache auch nicht
besser dass der herr sparen dann habe
ich den fokus dabei sekundiert hat der
herr sparen übrigens der offenbar mit
gesundheitspolitik nichts mehr mut der
macht jetzt in wirtschaft und energie
wahrscheinlich gibt es die bessere lobby
verträge ersparen also ein verlust für
die gesundheits
für die gesundheitspolitik ist das nicht
wenn ich mir diesen islamismus der
lauterbacher von hier vorne anschaue
dann bin ich der überzeugung kommen wir
brauchen eigentlich eher ein injektions
schutzgesetz als sein
infektionsschutzgesetz wenn sie weiter
hier als bundesminister arbeiten wollen
also wir arbeiten dran ein injektions
schutz gesetz auf den weg zu bringen
lauter werden wir reden heute auch über
die ausnahme vorschriften im bereich der
geschäftsordnung der parlamentarische
ausnahmezustand soll ja fortgesetzt
werden obwohl die pandemie weitestgehend
vorbei ist der paragraf 126 der
geschäftsordnung soll erstmal bis juli
verlängert werden sie haben sich bequem
eingerichtet was die arbeit in den
ausschüssen angeht das kann man
inzwischen zu hause vom sofa aus machen
man kann sich zuschalten lassen
natürlich trotzdem die tri trotzdem die
anwesenheit bescheinigt wir sagen weg
damit freiheitstag nicht nur in
deutschland freiheitstag auch im
deutschen bundestag wir brauchen im
deutschen bundestag genauso wenig wie in
der gesamten republik eine
ausnahmevorschrift mehr zurück zur
normalität das funktioniert nur mit der
freiheitspartei
der alternative für deutschland nur mit
der fraktion der alternative für
deutschland in diesem bundestag gesagt
lehnen wir die verlängerung der ausnahme
vorstellung ist fahrer 126 der
geschäftsordnung ab und lauterbach sie
erwarte jetzt von ihnen die
entschuldigung bessergegangen
zur zart besaitet oder er flüchtet er
weiter verdienen die entschuldigung die
konzerne von daraus machen
da bin ich zufrieden dankeschön
der verbrannten ist schon viereinhalb
jahren deutschen wohnhauses im bundestag
hat oder ob sie von den abläufen recht
wenig ahnung denn ein minister davon
seinem stehen
zwischen
intervention und ich nehme an dass
kanada was ich jetzt dazu melden wird
persönliche erklärung wird jetzt
angemeldet und im übrigen dass der herr
sparen jetzt die wirtschaft macht ist
auch völlig normal nämlich
ausgeschiedene bundesminister widmen
sich grundsätzlich einem anderen thema
das ist zwar nur uns so festgeschrieben
aber seit 70 jahren so üblich hier im
hohen hause
[Musik]
also eine kurze die funktion als
minister geht nicht von der minister
bank sondern war als aktuell
sprechen möchte ich sagen wir möchten
wir wollen uns hier nicht als lügner
diffamieren lassen das ist das rad noch
nicht
wir müssen uns nicht auslöser die
familien streit in der sache jeder zeit
aber hier haben unterschiedliche man
aber hier sprechen und was die
demokratischen parteien hier sprechen
keine lügner
haben sie schon von
lauterbach in der zeit so weit
gefallen nicht mehr der verdammte
[Applaus]
ob man dazu karl lauterbach gesagt
ein lügner ist in meinen augen jemanden
der mindestens einmal die unwahrheit
sagte vor die wahrheit kennt er was sie
erzählen uns seit zwei jahren am
laufenden band die unwahrheit obwohl sie
die wahrheit wahrscheinlich kennen also
seien sie froh dass ich sie lediglich
als lügner bezeichnet habe und nicht
noch andere wörter gewählt habt vielen
dank
dann haben wir das im protokoll
entsprechend vermerkt und
wir fahren in der debatte fort das wort
hat die kollegin christine
aschenberg-dugnus für die fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das was der
herr brandner heben gemacht hat ist
unanständig meine damen und herren das
gehört sich nicht in diesem deutschen
bundestag es ist unglaublich was sie
sich hier leisten
und in der ersten rede der afg wurde
behauptet es sei zu keiner zeit zu einer
überlastung der krankenhäuser gekommen
auch dass es eine unwahrheit was sie
hier behaupten wir haben noch vor kurzem
die patienten aus einzelnen
krankenhäusern ausgeflogen in andere
krankenhäuser weise überlastet waren
insofern erzählen sie auch die
unwahrheit hier und nehmen sie sich
einfach anständig und kollegial und da
wären wir schon zufrieden erwarten wir
von ihnen gar nicht so liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ich wiederhole es immer
wieder gebetsmühlenartig
selbstverständlich ist die pandemie noch
nicht vorbei aber die situation ist eine
andere als wären sie noch vor zwei
jahren hatten wir sind weit entfernt vor
den von den zuständen die wir hatten und
deswegen müssen wir eben auch andere
maßnahmen ergreifen als wenn sie vor
zwei jahren hatten wir müssen lernen mit
dem virus zu leben denn wir werden das
virus so schnell nicht los meine damen
und herren und deswegen sind die
geplanten vorliegenden änderungen im
infektionsschutzgesetz ein wichtiger
schritt in richtung normalität aber bei
gleichzeitiger handlungsfähigkeit und
das ist doch das wichtige an der ganzen
sache
das oberste ziel der kann die bekämpfung
war und ist es immer eine überlastung
des gesundheitswesens zu verhindern und
vor allem unsere vulnerable in gruppen
zu schützen und genau das setzen wir mit
diesem gesetz um wir müssen angemessen
und zielgerichtet agieren meine damen
und herren und wir schaffen wir auch
nicht alle maßnahmen ab so wie das hier
manchmal behauptet wird in bestimmten
bereichen wie in krankenhäusern alten-
und pflegeeinrichtungen einrichtungen
für menschen mit behinderung da wird
weiterhin mit tests und masken
gearbeitet meine damen und herren und an
einzelnen stellen haben wir auch
nachgeschärft beispielsweise das auch in
arztpraxen masken getragen werden müssen
aber völlig anderes sieht es im bereich
der schulen und kindertagesstätten aus
es macht doch ein unterschied ob sich
jüngere infizieren oder
risikopatienten und diesen unterschied
müssen wir auch bei den massnahmen
abbilden denn kinder haben
glücklicherweise einen wesentlich
milderen verlauf bei der omicron
variante und wir wissen doch alle
millionen flaschen dagegen deine sache
ich habe die uhr angehalten gestalten
sie eine frage oder bemerkungen der
kollegin lindholz welche fraktionen
cdu/csu
entschuldigung ja gerne
ja erst mal liebevoll aschenbrenner
duktus vielen dank für die zulassung der
zwischen frage
ich habe ihren ausführungen schon
diese woche beim letzten mal zugehört
und auch heute wieder und ich würde
ihnen gerne eine einen fall schildern
und fragen was wir diesen personen
antworten sollen sie sagen ja immer sie
schaffen die masten pflicht nicht ganz
ab sie lassen sie im kranken
krankenhäusern weiter zu sie lassen sie
im öffentlichen personennahverkehr
weiter bestehen sie lassen sie aber zum
beispiel nicht weiter bestehen im
bereich des öffentlichen lebens im
supermarkt und das lassen sie auch nicht
über den april hinaus bestehen und wir
haben eine instanz die heute bei aktuell
1600 irgendwas liegt also nahe 1700 wir
haben 2 180 todesfälle was sagen sie
einer krebskranken oder anders
schwerkranken jungen frau alten frau ein
mann also einer person die alles umgehen
kann die nicht in der gaststätte gehen
muss die vielleicht auch sich nicht
privat großtreffen muss die aber
zumindest zum einkaufen gehen muss und
beim einkaufen diese frau versucht alles
dieser man diese person um sich nicht zu
infizieren weil er sich mitten in einer
krebstherapie befindet was sagen sie
dieser person die möchte in zukunft in
den supermarkt gehen nach wie vor und
sie möchte in zukunft geschützt werden
aber sie ist in zukunft nicht mehr
geschützt sie selber kann ihre maske
aufziehen das stimmt aber ihr gegenüber
ihr gegenüber muss die maske im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr noch
aufziehen aber nicht im supermarkt was
sagen sie einer solchen person der wir
bei den jetzigen inzidenz und
todeszahlen die masken pflicht mit der
maske pflicht den schutz wegnehmen und
die kollegen von der fdp ich höre den
zwischenruf jedesmal und deswegen für
ich länger aus ja sie kann die maske
freiwillig aufsetzen aber ihr gegenüber
nicht und ein wirksamer schutz liebe
frau aschenberg dugnus liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen von der fdp erfordert ist
dass beide personen eine maske aufziehen
ich frage sie jetzt wie sie bei diesen
instanzen das gegenüber diesen wohl der
arabien personen vertreten können
sehr geehrte frau kollegin genau das
also entschuldigung bitten jetzt jetzt
kollegin lindholz das mikrofon ist aus
die frage ist verstanden und jetzt hat
die kollegin aschenberg dugnus das wort
für die beantwortung vielen dank für
ihre frage die wir ja häufiger von ihnen
hören und der von ihnen geschuldet
geschilderte fall würde ich sagen bitte
setzen sie die maske auf den eine ffp
zwei maske hat nachweisbar einen 34
fachen schutz und ist völlig ausreichend
um sich im leben bewegen zu können und
das können sie diesem dieser dame oder
diesem heraus sagen und dann geben sie
immer von den instanzen aus sie müssen
doch konstatieren dass wir jetzt ein
unterschied haben wir haben wahnsinnig
hohe fallzahlen aber auch heute wieder
wenn sie auf den export gehen sehen sie
das auch wieder die intensivpatienten
die zahl abgenommen hat das heißt mal
riesigen instanzen haben wir weniger
fälle auf den intensivstationen
das heißt das virus ist milder im
verlauf und erzählen sie den leuten doch
mal was positives dass sie sich mit
masken schützen können und dass wir zb
wenn sie auf den lkw bericht gehen auch
wesentlich weniger todesfälle haben als
noch in der vierten welle als wir jetzt
fast 3000 todesfälle pro woche hatten da
sind wir doch weit von entfernt sagen
sie das doch mal den leuten dass sie
auch sagen können sie können sich
schützen aber sie können auch am leben
teilnehmen als ihr solche
horrorszenarien über aufzuspielen
die perspektiven für die menschen geben
wir müssen doch sagen es geht weiter ihr
könnt wieder etwas tun und wenn sie
jetzt vom einkaufen reden ich weiß sie
wollen alles staatlich vorschreiben in
meinem heimatort strande war es schon
längst üblich da wo viele ältere sind da
gibt es da kann man zb vor ort auch
extra einkaufszeiten machen dann geht
man als als älterer mensch mit maske
dahin und hat spezielle einkauf sein es
gibt so viele möglichkeiten zu agieren
aber wir müssen doch auch sehen dass in
bestimmten bereichen und dazu komme ich
noch zum beispiel bei den kindern das
ist doch gerade fahrlässig ist da mit
einer massen pflicht zu arbeiten das
geht doch nicht und wir können doch
jetzt nicht liebt die bildungschancen
die sozialen chancen unserer kinder
aufrechnen gegen die wir wollen gruppen
mit unserem gesetz schützen wer die
wohlhabenden gruppen aber bieten unseren
kindern und jugendlichen auch die
möglichkeit bildung zu erlangen soziales
leben zu erlangen und das ist doch genau
das was wir wollen frau kollegin
und deswegen auswahl neben ausgeführten
können sie hören dass es bleibt dabei
eine frage die rede
kollegen lindholz ich habe heute zu
beginn unserer debatte die geltenden
regeln die wir seit mittwoch auch
durchhalten läutet wir lassen je rede
eine frage und antwort zu nach wie vor
ist die zeit nicht limitiert das ist
denke ich jetzt auch
beantwortet und jetzt bitte ich hier in
der debatte vor zuschauen wie die wurde
die studentin ich fahre ford aus dem
eben gesagten können sie hören oder
können sie heraus hören wie wichtig uns
die bildungschancen und unsere kinder
sind in dem wir sie eben nicht mehr dazu
zwingen maske zu tragen und damit sind
wir auch mit vielen kinderpsychologen
einer meinung viele kinderärzte fordern
dass auch das ist also nicht nur die fdp
auch uns überhaupt der kollege wiese hat
es ja geschildert herr söder schafft er
jetzt die masken pflicht auch ab in den
augen grundschulen also so schlecht kann
unser gesetz doch gar nicht sein auf der
einen seite fordern sie allgemeine
masken pflicht aber wenn es dann zum
schwur kommt der aktien sieht auch
anders wie zum beispiel herr söder also
bei ihnen stimmt auch in der
argumentation ganz vieles nicht weil
damen und herren so und jetzt noch mal
zu meckern sie hat nun mal andere
freundin als die delta variante und
deswegen müssen wir eben auch andere
maßnahmen ergreifen und ich möchte
abschließend noch mal betonen und das
ist das positive wir sind doch den virus
nicht hilflos ausgesetzt sie haben gut
funktionierende impfung deswegen lassen
sie sich impfen lassen sie sich bewusst
sein wir haben medikamente aber was ich
sagen muss wir laufen leider immer der
entwicklung hinterher und deswegen
werden wir als cooler koalition jetzt
auch ein frühwarnsystem auf den weg
bringen das ist uns als fdp ganz
besonders wichtig mit mit einem abwasser
monitoring- oder zb mit repräsentativen
studien damit wir genau wissen was im
herbst winter auf uns zukommt und um
dann mit diesem gesetz zielgerichtet zu
agieren das sind wir der bevölkerung
schuldig zielgerichtet und nicht einfach
nur so quer geht dankeschön für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
weil das eben optima in der
auseinandersetzung war häufig der
nochmal aus die instanz heute bei
3.700 6,3 das ist die höchste instanz
die in deutschland gemessen wurde
297.000
845 personen sind heute aktuell erkrankt
und
226 tote sind in den letzten 24 stunden
verstorbenen
von der spd einer der neuen abgeordneten
heute mit seiner ersten rede vor dem
hohen hause
[Applaus]
als erstes möchte ich erstmal
genesungswünsche ausrichten an unserem
kollegen manuel gahr er ist leider an
corona krank er hätte heute wie die rede
gehalten
wir beraten heute neben einer änderung
des infektionsschutzgesetzes auch das
sozialdienstleister einsatz gesetz
dessen verlängerung und weiter
regelungen dieses leistet und bereits
seit beginn der pandemie wertvolle
dienste indem es den einsatz von
sozialen dienstleistern zur
krisenbewältigung sichert und die
wirtschaftliche leistungsfähigkeit
aufrecht erhält die sozialen
dienstleister hierzu zählen
beispielsweise den werkstätten von
menschen mit behinderung rea und
versorgungseinrichtungen sowie die
anbieter von sprachkursen leisten bei
der gesellschaftlichen krisen bewältigen
unverzichtbare arbeit und stellen daher
eine wichtige säule der pandemie
bekämpfung da die
den bestand oder sozialen infrastruktur
maßgeblich hat leider ist die pandemie
immer noch nicht überwunden so dass auch
die sozialen dienstleister corona
bedingt wirtschaftliche belastungen
unterliegen und daher weiterhin auf
finanzielle unterstützung angewiesen
sind die situation der sind der sozialen
dienstleister stark von weiteren
infektionsschutz maßnahmen abhängig und
somit mit ungewissheit und großer
unsicher mit dem sieg steht uns ein
wichtiges effektives instrument zur
verfügung das dazu geeignet ist die
unsicherheiten aufzufangen und damit die
wichtige wichtiges politisches signal zu
setzen dass in einer unsicheren zeit
beständigkeit und sicherheit vermittelt
auch wenn damit zu rechnen ist dass die
infektionszahlen während der
sommermonate wieder rückläufig sein
werden ist es wichtig dass wir gerade
auch im hinblick auf unsicherheiten bzw
möglicherweise neu auftauchende
virusvarianten oder bevorstehende
urlaubssaison mit umsicht und
vorausschauend handeln und
handlungsfähig bleibt dabei ist jedoch
zu betonen dass die verlängerung des so
decks keine finanziellen belastungen
ausgehen sofern keine weiteren maßnahmen
nach infektionsschutzgesetz
ergriffen werden müssen die verlängerung
des rolex erhalten wir nicht nur eine
wichtige rechtsgrundlage aufrecht die es
den leistungsträgern weiterhin
ermöglicht zahlungen an den sozialen
dienstleistern zu leisten sondern
sichern zugleich auch eine reihe von
maßnahmen die sich in vergangenheit
bewährt gemacht haben die zu
beschließenden maßnahmen enden
spätestens am 23 september 2022 um zu
erreichen dass das ende september tat
sich eine weitere maßnahme nicht mutter
nicht sind ist unser wichtiges mittel
die korona schutzimpfung unser und
stehen in deutschland nicht nur sicherer
sondern auch wirksamer impfstoff zur
verfügung
[Applaus]
nach wie vor sind die impfquoten nicht
hoch genug gerade deshalb ist es auch
weiterhin besonders wichtig denn
augenmerk auf betriebliche
infektionsschutz maßnahmen zu legen um
sichere arbeitsbedingungen zu
gewährleisten für die kolleginnen
kolleginnen hierzu zählen vor allen
dingen auch die haarige testungen sowie
das angebot von impfungen gerade diese
maßnahmen haben sich in vergangenheit
vergangenheit mit großem nutzen bewährt
mit der verlängerung des vig wird
darüber hinaus dafür sorge getragen dass
pandemie bedingte soziale risiken
abgefedert werden dass die erhöhung der
kinder krankentage zum beispiel von 10
auf 30 tagen die lebensrealität von
erwerbstätigen eltern entspricht haben
wir gesehen daran dass er die
krankenkassen in 2021 mehr als doppelt
so viele anträge verzeichneten wie noch
in 2020 auch in den kommenden monaten
muss damit gerechnet werden dass kinder
sich auch wenn sie nicht selbst erkrankt
sind in isolation oder quarantäne
begeben müssen die fortschreibung der
erhöhung der kinder krankentage ist
folglich unerlässlich damit kinder damit
eltern ihre kinder pflegen und betreuen
können
die erhöhung der kinder krankentage war
zwar aus anlass der pandemie eingeführt
allerdings habe ich auch als vater eine
mittlerweile fünf jahre alten tochter
die erfahrung gemacht dass die
bisherigen anzahl der kinder krankentage
vor allen dingen während der kita
eingewöhnungszeit nicht ausreichte auch
unabhängig von der pandemie lage wäre
einer höhe dieser wünschenswert
nicht nur im hinblick auf die kubakrise
gilt dass wir dafür sorge tragen müssen
dass alle menschen die darauf angewiesen
sind ausreichend unterstützung erhalten
und rückhalt durch den sozialstaat
erfahren die in vielen jahrzehnten
gewachsene soziale infrastruktur ist
systemrelevant und muss daher gerade
jetzt in zeiten der krise besonders
unterstützt werden im verlauf der
pandemie konnten durch die finanzielle
unterstützung nachdem
sozialdienstleister einsatz gesetz
zahlreiche sozialen dienstleister wie
zum beispiel reaktivieren oder
vorsorgeeinrichtungen vor der schließung
bewahrt werden dieser status gilt es zu
erhalten die verlängerung des
sozialdiensts ansatz ist daher
unverzichtbar zum schluss meiner rede
bleibt ist mir zu bitten um zustimmung
zu dieser vorlage
wir starten mit besonders viel applaus
seine erste reden hier für die spd im
wohnhaus der bundestag debattiert über
die änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
zweiter und dritter lesung daher wird es
dazu eine namentliche abstimmung geben
um party mit mustern der bundesrat noch
zustimmen
die
kollegen
von der fdp bin ich in unserem
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten markus
söder sehr dankbar dass er die masken
pflicht in den grundschulen abschafft
wir lassen die kinder dort in den schule
nicht alleine
denn mit
regelmäßigen tests und auch mit
lüftungsanlagen die durchaus regelmäßig
in den schulen vorhanden sind schaffen
wir einen nötigen schutz und
gleichzeitig gehen wir auf die
bedürfnisse der kinder ein denn es ist
klar so dass wenn der spracherwerb und
der ist in der grundschule besonders im
fokus getätigt werden muss ist es
entscheidend den gegenüber ins gesicht
schauen zu können auch die
mundbewegungen schauen zu können und
deshalb bin ich sehr froh dass wir in
bayern diesen schritt abgebogen gegangen
sind nichtsdestotrotz sind sie natürlich
sehr inkonsequent in ihrer argumentation
denn wenn auf der einen seite mit
bundesminister lauterbach eben seine
gesetzliche regelung darstellt das eben
hotspots auch ganze bundesländer
betrifft und gleichzeitig sie als fdp
davon sprechen dass nur einzelne
landkreise betroffen sein könnten dann
passt etwas nicht zusammen sie sind
nicht eins in der ampelkoalition und es
lassen wir ihnen auch nicht durchgehen
und nicht schlecht gehen lassen ihnen
dass auch die ministerpräsidenten der
länder und das sind also mit verlaub
wenn nicht nur unionsgeführte länder
dabei sondern natürlich auch die
landesminister präsidenten von spd und
mit natürlich beteiligung auch der fdp
deswegen es passt in ihrem gesetz ganz
offensichtlich etwas nicht zusammen und
auch in den massnahmen passend passen
dinge nicht zusammen denn sie geben auf
der einen seite weiterhin warnungen aus
und gleichzeitig schaffen sie
beispielsweise die unterstützungen die
versorgungs aufschläge
ausgleichszahlungen für krankenhäusern
für arztpraxen ab auch damit lassen sie
gerade krankenhäusern im ländlichen raum
arztpraxen im regen stehen und es geht
in einer reihe damit und deswegen haben
wir als union auch einen änderungsantrag
eingebracht den sie wahrscheinlich nicht
gelesen haben aber ich werde es sehr
dafür dass zu tun nämlich dass wir eben
auch bonuszahlungen für die fordern die
eben die notaufnahmen leer gehalten
haben und dass der pflege bonus das
wurde kritisiert von unserem
gesundheitsminister holly check aber
auch vom kollegen czaja dass er immer
noch nicht auf den weg gebracht wurde
das ist ein skandal dass ist
arbeitsverweigerung was sie hier tun und
das bei diesem
pflege bonus hier jetzt angedacht ist
dass dort die medizinischen
fachangestellten
zahnmedizinischen fachangestellten und
auch mitarbeiter im rettungswesen keine
berücksichtigung finden auch das finde
ich empörend denn auch sie waren es die
maßgeblich dazu beigetragen haben dass
die impfkampagne funktioniert hat dass
die leute schnell von a nach b gekommen
sind dass die leute in der quarantäne
nicht einfach ab wenn ab administriert
wurden sondern dass sie ansprechpartner
hatten und deswegen gehört es sich
meiner meinung nach dass wir diesen
bonus einführen nicht nur für die pflege
auch für die mitarbeiter im
rettungswesen auch für die medizinischen
fachangestellten und deswegen vor der
sie ganz konkret aus gehen sie mit uns
einen schritt weiter fortschritts
koalition wir wollen zukunft gestalten
wir wollen einen bund länder gipfel für
die reform der ausbildung der
medizinischen fachangestellten das
betrifft rund 500.000 vor allem frauen
in unserem land da müssen wir handeln da
müssen wir zukunft gestalten und
deswegen lesen sie den antrag der
unionsfraktion und schaffen sie mit uns
gemeinsam einen bonus der über dem
pflege bonus hinausgeht danke
[Applaus]
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
hat nun der kollege helge limburg das
wort
demo kisten rechtspolitischen sprecher
und dem bündnis
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ihre frau
kollegin seiner 1 habe ich nicht
verstanden ihrer vorbemerkung den
verständlichen wunsch dass die massen
pflicht im grundschulen feld zu begrüßen
und anschließend das gesetz was genau
diesen wunsch erst ermöglicht abzulehnen
das passt für mich nicht zusammen
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen viele menschen möchten endlich
ohne impfnachweis und ohne maske
einkaufen ohne maske im theater oder
kino sitzen oder fahrzeuge hat gesagt
ohne maske in der schule sitzen und
dieser wunsch ist verständlich
der muss auch nicht gerechtfertigt oder
begründet werden ein freier
demokratischer rechtsstaat darauf hat
der köder zu recht hingewiesen muss jede
grundrecht einschränkung begründen und
nicht die bürgerinnen und bürger müssen
begründen warum sie keine massen
aber genauso verständlich und legitim
ist eben auch der wunsch von menschen
und zwar auch von menschen mit
vorerkrankungen von wohlhabenden gruppen
und anderen am sozialen leben teilhaben
zu können zum beispiel den supermarkt
für einander geschäften einkaufen zu
können ohne die sorge haben zu müssen
sich dabei mit dem chor ohne näheres zu
infizieren
auch die können sich auch pflichten des
staates nämlich auch schutzpflichten
beruf natürlich kann es einen
komplettschutz nicht geben aber ich kann
schon die leute verstehen die sagen naja
müsst ihr angesichts dieser doch sehr
hohen infektionszahlen wo die
wahrscheinlichkeit sich anzustecken
relativ groß ist denn gerade solche
lockerungen vornehmen insofern ist es
kein geheimnis war cover band hat der
autor charles gesagt dass ich meine
fraktion eine weitergehende masken
pflicht in innenräumen sehr gut hätte
vorstellen können und dass es dazu
verschiedene sichtweisen in der
ampelkoalition gibt aber richtig ist
eben auch und darauf ist zu recht
hingewiesen und es ist nicht so dass
dieser gesetzentwurf keine maßnahmen
mehr ermöglicht die hotspot regelung die
unter beteiligung der jeweiligen landtag
und das ist doch beste föderale
demokratische tradition mit zustimmung
der landtage
geschaffen wird ermöglicht eben
weitergehende maßnahmen zum beispiel die
von ihnen geforderten masken pflichten
auch in innenräumen und ich finde es
schon sehr wichtig was der kollege wiese
gesagt habe wir sollten jetzt
verstanden sie eine frage oder bemerkung
und cdu/csu von dem schock
ich meine demokratischen rechte er sorge
da
sehr gerne hamburg vielen dank für ihre
ausführungen zur hotspot regelung wir
haben bereits in der ersten lesung im
deutschen bundestag als auch heute
unterschiedliche auffassungen aus der
ampel koalition zum thema hotspot gehört
es fehlen nur noch die ausführung der
grünen der bundesgesundheitsminister hat
gesagt hotspot können ganze länder seien
auch die kollegin aus der spd hat in der
ersten lesung gesagt hotspot können
ganze länder seien ganze bundesländer
wie beispielsweise schleswig-holstein
sachsen-anhalt baden-württemberg die
freien demokraten sagen die
gebietskörperschaft ist der landkreis
vollkommen allein jetzt frage ich sie
wie sehen bündnis 90 die grünen dass bei
diesen instanzen bei diesen krankheits
belastung wie ist die sprenz scharfe
abgrenzung eines hotspots sind das ganze
bundesländer flächenbundesländer oder
sind das lediglich kleine städte und
kleine landkreise
vielen dank die werk kollege für die
frage weil es mir in der tat ermöglicht
einen wichtigen aspekten der debatte
noch mal näher zu erläutern sie kennen
genau wie ich den spruch ein blick ins
gesicht er leicht ins gesetz erleichtert
die rechtsfindung von ihm gesetzt
und
und und wir setzt sich in der tat von
gebietskörperschaften die rede sie
wissen dass gebietskörperschaften städte
sein können gemeint sein können lang
sein können aber das natürlich auch
länder gebietskörperschaften sind und
insofern
das ist das ist ja nichts neues
und insofern geht das gesetz mit dem
unbestimmten rechtsbegriffen die die
kriterien dastehen ist ja nicht nur ein
kriterium sind verschiedene kriterien
angelegt aufgrund welcher unbestimmten
rechtsbegriffe einen hotspot
festgestellt werden kann natürlich wird
es im regelfall zu sein wenn sie sich
die inzidenz und auch die krankenhaus
belegung andere situation zusammen lang
anschauen das im regelfall hotspots auf
landkreise oder regionen begrenzt sind
aber natürlich ist nicht ausgeschlossen
im gesetz wenn sie insbesondere an die
bundesländer hamburg bremen oder auch
das saarland denken oder auch in
besonderen situationen weitere
bundesländer das ein ganzes bundesland
zum hotspot erklärt wird aber herr
kollege diese entscheidung und das finde
ich auch wirklich richtig obliegt den
dafür gewählten landesparlamenten wir
als deutsche bundestag und die minister
pendelte sich davor hüten die arbeit der
landesparlamente gering zu schätzen ich
weiß aus eigener erfahrung ich teile das
ja mit vier kolleginnen kollegen hier im
haus wie professionell gearbeitet wird
und darum dass es den richtigen händen
liebe
kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich habe es jetzt mehrfach ausgeführt
werden uns weitergehende maßnahmen
vorstellen können aber politik ist immer
auch die kunst der kompromissfindung und
wir haben hier ein kompromiss gefunden
der handhabbar und händler ist der den
landtagen viel verantwortung überträgt
für die sie auch gewählt für sie
ausgewählt sind und wir haben aber das
ist mir noch wichtig zu betonen am ende
wir haben die klare vereinbarung in der
ampelkoalition
und es gibt nach dem bisherigen
zusammenarbeit auch keinen zweifel daran
dass diese vereinbarung gilt das wenn
wir feststellen kollege köhler hat sie
auch noch mal gesagt wenn wir
feststellen dass die heute zu
beschließenden regelungen dann eben doch
nicht ausreichen wenn wir feststellen
dass die sorgen die viele hier in der
heutigen debatte geäußert haben die
menschen draußen äußern dass die
berechtigt sind dann werden wir
natürlich als ampel koalition insgesamt
und das schnell noch mal zusammentreten
und gegebenenfalls nachbessern liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen normalerweise
hofft man als politiker ja dass man
recht behält ich muss ihnen offen sagen
heute hoffe ich dass die kollegin
kapitals kollege und ich uns irren und
wir mit unseren befürchtungen und sorgen
nicht recht behalten aber wie gesagt
wenn es so ist dass diese regeln
wenn es so ist dass diese regelung nicht
ausreichen dann werden wir hier schnell
noch mal zusammenkommen diese
handlungsfähigkeit haben wir den
vergangenen monaten bewiesen und wir
werden sie auch in den kommenden monaten
an den tag legen vielen dank wieder
aufmerksam
der bundesgesetzgeber geschichte den
rahmen für das infektionsschutzgesetz
und deswegen ist der erhofften hoffnung
die rahmenbedingungen festzulegen im
bundesgesundheitsministerium gab es in
der frage hotspot ein gutachten und dort
wurde dann festgelegt die kriterien
müssen möglichst eng und präzise
definiert sein und es gab dann
tatsächlich eine auseinandersetzung
schlichten den bundesjustizminister und
dem bundesgesundheitsminister was das
damals zu bedeuten hat karl lauterbach
sie haben uns sicherlich mitbekommen
sieht die möglichkeit dass einzelne
länder zum hot spot erklärt werden
können genau wie helge limburg der
redner gerade der
bundesjustizminister sah das vor drei
tagen noch ganz anders wie das jetzt ist
bleibt unklar und das ist eine
diskussion die sicherlich gleich auch
unter den ministerpräsidenten
der kammer die auch noch über dieses
gesetz abstimmen am heutigen tag in
einer sondersitzung nur einmal zur
sprache kommt die unklare definition und
der verweis von herrn limburg auf die
frage wer das denn eigentlich genau fest
zu denen hat das dass die
länderparlamente machen sollen dass es
natürlich müßig es ist der
bundesgesetzgeber der dieses gesetz hier
einbringt in der parlamente können nur
den rahmen noch dann exekutieren ob sie
definieren können dass sie
wahrscheinlich wird es so sein da rein
so offen ist ob seine bewegung
etwas die parlamente tatsächlich
aufgerufen sind um es dann selber
definieren so jetzt geht es hier weiter
in der debatte hat als
für die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion diana stöcker
sie ist mitglied im gesundheitsausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir alle wissen
es seit monaten morgen am 19 läuft das
infektionsschutzgesetz aus es gab
keinerlei vorausschauende vorbereitung
der ampelkoalition in einem hauruck
verfahren muss das gesetz in fünf tagen
durchgezogen werden im ergebnis und ein
handwerklich schlecht es nicht
ausgereiftes konzept das von experten in
der öffentlichen anhörung am letzten
montag auseinandergenommen wurde von uns
von ihnen bis heute nicht wesentlich
nachgebessert wurde einen solch
schlechten gesetzentwurf können wir als
unions fraktion nur ablehnen
auf die bundesländer sprechen sich
mehrheitlich dieses gesetz aus war
vorhin schon ein paar mal die rede davon
den kündigen bereits jetzt an dass sie
den aktuellen handlungsoptionen so lange
nutzen werden wie es irgend möglich ist
um die pandemie zu bekämpfen in der
öffentlichen debatte am mittwoch und
auch heute wieder haben wir abgeordnete
ihrer regierungskoalition gehört die
gesagt haben dass das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz ein großer
kompromiss sei der die artikulation
abbildet sie hätten sich ein anderes
gesetz gewünscht würden den ländern gern
einen breiteren instrumenten katalog zur
verfügung stellen aber diese
minimallösung sei eben demokratie
sprich es ist der kleinste gemeinsame
nenner der in ihrer koalition möglich
ist diesen satz werden wir meine
prognose noch öfter hören
demokratie heißt aber nicht nur einen
minimalkonsens in einer
regierungskoalition herzustellen sondern
mit verantwortung und vernunft
entscheidungen zu treffen und zu handeln
minister habeck sagte gestern bei seinem
statement zu impfpflicht in vorsorge-
und verantwortung denken aber beim
infektionsschutzgesetz geht es plötzlich
nicht mehr sie haben die pflicht ältere
und immunschwache menschen zu schützen
aber sie heben die masken pflicht
weitgehend auf schaffen einen
flickenteppich und mit einer schwammigen
hotspot strategie wo gehobelt wird
fallen späne aber bei ihnen fällt
sprichwörtlich buchstäblich der ganze
komplette werkzeugkasten auseinander am
mittwoch habe ich mit dem leiter des
welcome centers für geflüchtete aus der
ukraine im berliner hauptbahnhof
gesprochen er berichtete jeder dritte
der bislang 150000 geflüchteten aus der
ukraine hat es positiv auf grüner
getestet menschen die in überfüllten
zügen unterwegs waren und nun in
gemeinschaftsunterkünften zusammenleben
und in dieser krise wird das
infektionsschutzgesetz auf ein minimum
reduziert nehmen sie von der
ampelkoalition diesen widerspruch
überhaupt war
wir befinden uns im krisenmodus schon in
normalen zeiten hatte sich nie
ausgezahlt abzuwarten
aber die aktuelle zögerliche haltung
dass ständige auf der bremse stehen wenn
es um vorausschauendes zupacken des
handelns halt handeln geht wird ihnen
auf die füße fallen sie sind sehenden
auges in diese situation rein gerasselt
und sie werden mit dem gesetzentwurf
ihrer verantwortung gegenüber der
bevölkerung nicht gerecht
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege jens park für
die spd bot
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren heute
diskutieren wir das
infektionsschutzgesetz sowie weitere
gesetzliche regelungen zu einer dieser
regelung die verbesserung beim
kurzarbeitergeld möchte ich für meine
fraktion hier was sagen weil es für die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer in
unserem land gerade in der jetzigen
situation von besonderer bedeutung ist
vor vier wochen haben wir hier im haus
die verlängerung der krise bedingten
sonderregelung des kurzarbeitergeldes im
grundsatz beschlossen vor vier wochen
bestand auch noch die vorsichtige
zuversicht dass eine erholung auf dem
arbeitsmarkt gibt und dass wir nicht
alle sonder regelungen die winterkrone
krise hatten weiter verlängern müssen
dass wir uns auf dem weg zur normalität
befinden sechs tage später
mit dem überfall putins auf die ukraine
ist eine rückkehr zur normalität in
weite ferne gerückt
präsident seelands die hat das hier
gestern in diesem haus sehr eindrücklich
geschildert und die schrecken des
krieges deutlich gemacht
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir handeln
die bundesregierung hat umfangreiche
sanktionen gegen das system putin auf
den weg gebracht das war notwendig und
das war richtig aber
krieg um sanktionen werden auch an uns
nicht spurlos vorbeigehen es fehlen
rohstoffe wegen mangelnder halbleiter
und kabelbäume musste die autoindustrie
bereits zu drosseln in teilen einstellen
sind davon ausgehen dass bis juni
400.000 1 5 millionen fahrzeuge das
entspricht zehn prozent jährliche
produktion wenig geht werden können
heute morgen ticker dass der mangel hat
dieser stillstand kostet auch uns
aber eins darf auf keinen fall kosten
und das sind arbeitsplätze
deswegen
gilt das war zu halten vor allem monat
zu grundüberzeugung dieser
regierungskoalition gesagt habe auch
heute wir lassen niemanden im stich
deshalb werden wir die leier bald mit
der änderung die wir hiermit beschließen
wieder in das kurzarbeitergeld aufnehmen
in der ukraine krieg ist kein branche
mögliches risiko und die
automobilindustrie auf den einsatz von
leiharbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern
angewiesen weiter ermöglichen wir der
bundesregierung bei außergewöhnlichen
verhältnissen auf dem arbeitsmarkt
schnell zu reagieren und bei rechts
worden die sozialversicherungsbeiträge
wieder teilweise oder auch vollständig
zu erstatten denn ist vollkommen klar
und da sind uns einig wir alle können
nicht vorhersehen wie sich dieser
konflikt entwickeln wird und was noch
auf uns zukommt mit dieser massnahme
stellen wir die handlungsfähigkeit der
bundesregierung im ernstfall sicher die
sozialpolitik darf nicht immer nur
hinten dranhängen reparatur politik sein
sollen sie muss vorausschauend agieren
wir alle wissen die erstattung der
sozialbeiträge kann teuer sein
bundesminister hat in seiner rede vor
vier wochen hier deutlich gemacht dass
die 26 milliarden rücklage der ba
aufgebraucht sind kurzarbeit hat bisher
42 milliarden euro gekostet aber uns
auch eins wichtig ebenso wenig wie bei
der äußeren sicherheit darf man eher
sozialen sicherheit und dem inneren
zusammenhalt unserem land sparen
und deshalb
wende ich zum schluss meiner rede blickt
noch einmal auf die nächste woche in der
wir hier im bundestag über den haushalt
sprechen werden und ich sage ganz
deutlich wir dürfen nicht nur auf die
ausgaben schauen sondern auch auf die
einnahmen wir brauchen geld um diese
herausfordern das habe ich ganz klar
starke schultern müssen mehr tragen als
schwache banken stimmen
hinter das für die studierenden
ausschuss für arbeit und soziales der
bundestag debattierte in zweiter lesung
die änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
normalerweise würden alle regelungen am
samstagabend auf sonntag auslaufen der
gesetzgeber lässt hier eingesetzt dass
es einen basisschutz gibt in
krankenhäuser pflegeeinrichtungen
asylbewerberheimen und öffentlichem
nahverkehr werden weiter masken getragen
sind auch textlich möglichkeiten
gibt es eine sonderregelung wenn es dann
doch zum kommt
dass es unterstützungsmaßnahmen gibt die
es gilt zu verlängern so auch das
sozialdienstleister einsatz gesetzes
dass wir in der letzten
legislaturperiode bereits auf den weg
gebracht haben und dass ja die
zielrichtung hatte gerade einrichtungen
der
arbeitsmarktpolitik der rehabilitation
und der behindertenhilfe finanziell zu
unterstützen
damit sie aufgrund der einschränkenden
maßnahmen die sie durch die korona
pandemie finanziell nicht in die
schieflage geraten und auch weiterhin
bestehen können und
das gesetz hat in seiner wirkung auch
gezeigt dass es richtig war dies zu
machen und dass die wirkungen auch
entsprechend da waren wenn man sieht
dass etwa 25.000 anträge gestellt worden
sind und die auch bewilligt worden sie
einrichtungen eben nicht schließen
sondern eben weiterhin auch arbeiten
können unter erschwerten maßnahmen aber
auch existieren können so war das
unwahrscheinlich wichtig und richtig
dieses gesetz damals zu machen und auch
wenn jetzt die
einschränkenden maßnahmen vielleicht
zurückgenommen werden so steht ja aber
auch im infektionsschutzgesetz von dass
die länder ja gegebenenfalls ja die
maßnahme wieder aufgreifen können und da
jetzt vorsorge zu betreiben
damit dieses gesetz dann auch sofort
wirken kann wenn die länder sich für
solche schritte entscheiden halten wir
von der cdu csu fraktion für vollkommen
richtig und unterstützen damit auch
diese verlängerung des
sozialdienstleister einsatz gesetzes
neben
neben dieser maßnahme werden aber auch
weitere ohne sonderregelungen durch eine
verordnungsermächtigung eben auf
verlängert und das halten wir auch für
wichtig ich darf sie in kürze auf zähne
arbeitsschutz rechtliche grundlagen für
betriebliche infektions maßnahmen oder
corona bedingte anpassungen von
vergütungsvereinbarungen zwischen den
trägern der zugelassenen vorsorge und
rehabilitationseinrichtungen und den
krankenkassen oder zum beispiel den
einsatz von vorsorge- und
rehabilitationseinrichtungen als ersatz
krankenhäuser bei pandemie bedingter
kapazitätsengpässen zugelassener
krankenhäuser das zeigt dass der
maßnahmenkatalog vollumfänglich
erweitert wird und verlängert wird das
finden wir
gut für die zukunft hoffen wir dass eine
weitere verlängerung jetzt nicht nötig
wäre weil das würde bedeuten dass die
lage sich verbessert aber wenn es doch
absehbar ist dass es eben nicht der fall
ist dann bitten wir darum diese
verlängerungs gesetze vielleicht auch
frühzeitiger einzubringen herzlichen
dank
[Applaus]
damen und herren mit der letzte redner
hier in der debatte ist erwin rüddel von
der cdu/csu in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode der 40 des
gesundheitsausschusses und danach kommt
es hier zu namen
meine damen und herren der vorliegende
gesetzentwurf der koalition macht
einigermaßen ratlos denn die intention
ist grundsätzlich richtig
im gegensatz zur umsetzung natürlich ist
es richtig nach zwei jahren pandemie
bedingter einschränkung den weg zurück
in die normalität zu finden und
natürlich ist es sinnvoll
weitere lockerungen zu beschließen und
die masken pflicht zum beispiel den
schulen und kitas abzuschaffen die
verhältnisse haben sich gravierend
verändert wir haben impfstoffe wir haben
medikamente und wir haben eine mutation
die milde verläufe
vorzeigt wir müssen lernen mit dem virus
zu leben und die einschränkungen im
alltag müssen möglichst auf ein minimum
reduziert werden soweit so gut aber
handwerklich ist der vorliegende entwurf
eine katastrophe
inhaltliche unklarheiten und präzise
formulierungen
unterschiedliche
interpretationen aus der den reihen der
koalition das alles summiert sich zu
einem abbild der zerrissenheit der ampel
in dieser frage ob es um fehlende
definitionen für klinik überlastungen
geht ob es um die hotspot regelung geht
ob es um die rolle der landtage geht
überall fehlt es an klarheit und an
schlüssigen vorgaben die verlängerung
der übergangszeiten durch diverse
ländern gibt bereits einen vorgeschmack
auf das was uns
künftig erwarten wird verschlimmert wird
alles nur noch durch den
gesundheitsminister der trägt
zuverlässig zur weiteren verunsicherung
der menschen bei indem er den kompromiss
der koalition
gleichzeitig lobt und schlecht redet
anstatt wenigstens zu versuchen die
mühsame einigung der ampel verständlich
zu kommunizieren
redet der minister so als wenn er in
opposition zu dem antrag stehen würde so
kann das nicht weitergehen
andere länder in europa haben viel
früher geöffnet doch der minister
beschwört mit vorliebe unseren angeblich
schlechten corona status übrigens in
seiner amtszeit unser gesundheitssystem
verkraftet auch das weil die inzidenz
eben nicht gleichbedeutend ist mit
überforderung
entscheidend ist die tatsächliche
belastung des gesundheitssystems meine
damen und herren ich bin grundsätzlich
für mehr mut und für mehr freiheit in
eigenverantwortung
deshalb hätte ich gern diesem antrag
zugestimmt der vorliegende entwurf macht
es mir aber leider unmöglich
[Applaus]
ich schließe die aussprache wir kommen
zur abstimmung über den von den
fraktionen der spd bündnis 90/die grünen
und fdp
eingebrachten gesetzentwurf zur änderung
des infektionsschutzgesetzes
und anderer vorschriften der ausschuss
für gesundheit empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf den drucksachen
1070 und
1094 den gesetzentwurf der fraktion der
spd bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp auf
drucksachen
958 in der ausschuss fassung anzunehmen
mir liegt eine vielzahl von erklärungen
nach § 31 unserer geschäftsordnung tour
entsprechend unserer geschäftsordnung
nehmen wir diese erklärung zu protokoll
ich werde nun diejenigen die dem
gesetzentwurf in der ausschuss fassung
zustimmen wollen um das handzeichen
dankeschön bestimmt dagegen
dankeschön wer enthält sich niemand der
gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
tschuldigung
der gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
beratung
mit den stimmen der fraktionen der spd
bündnis 90 die grünen und der fdp gegen
die stimmen der cdu csu fraktion der afg
fraktion und der fraktion die linke
angenommen bei enthaltung des
abgeordneten matthias birkwald
dritte beratung und schlussabstimmung
die fraktionen der cdu/csu und der afg
haben namentliche abstimmung verlangt
die abstimmung erfolgt in der best lobby
sie haben zur abgabe ihrer stimme nach
eröffnung der abstimmung 20 minuten zeit
bitte denken sie daran dass wir
unmittelbar nach eröffnung der
namentlichen abstimmung noch weitere
abstimmungen durchführen werden man hat
ja und hier sehen sie die air west lobby
die abgeordneten haben sich schon vor
den rängen versammelt also dieses
wichtige gesetz das hat die opposition
verlangt mussten namentlich abgestimmt
werden ein bisschen misslich aber wir
haben es ja noch relativ früh am tag
denn der bundesrat kommt heute zu einer
sondersitzung zusammen und muss diesem
gesetz ja auch noch zustimmen und wird
das wohl auch tun denn es ist ein
einspruchgesetz ich hab's verschenkt
erklärt in der bundesrat dieses neue
gesetz sozusagen in den
vermittlungsausschuss holen würde dann
die die klärung dieser sache so lange
dauern dass die übergangsfristen die
meisten länder ziehen wollen bis anfang
april bis zum 2 april dann schon längst
vorbei wäre und insofern wird das im
bundesrat sicherlich klar gehen hier im
bundestag hat die ampel eine ordentliche
mehrheit nicht alle bei der spd und den
grünen waren so richtig überzeugt aber
im notfall steht natürlich die mehrheit
der hamburger fange ich mit zu handeln